Phang Tinh Røy Tư sẹp 7 năm, tôi chứ gây tịch dơ về các phát tổ đã tuyên bố,
đợi bùng phát dịch ở bố là tại công hoa dân chủ công gố và uống hành ra,
là tình chẳng khẩn các bi tế công cậm măng tầm của tế,
về các phát tổ nhận đệm.
Muy có lấy làm, sản thức khu rà lắng dàng là dứt cao,
dô đợi bùng phát hiện chưa đa bùng tư chi của một đại dịch quan cầu.
Về các phát tổ cũng cho biết,
dịch bệnh là n quang tự trùng viên rôs,
bún gì, bún hiểu,
lại hiện chưa có bác xin hoa thu dự chi đặc hiệu được phía dùi dùi,
tại tình nghĩ chú rí của công cầu giới trước khi nhận tảm vi cà tự vòng,
nhi linh quan tế bố là công hoa hành chăm càng nhi nhận tạng nhiều khu vực đi tế.
Bù gần ra cũng sân nhận một số các bạn có linh quan tự người dí chuyển từ công cầu.
Theo Về các phát tổ, sửa lấy làm cuối tế để được khi nhận,
các quan này quín cao cơn nước tăng cường giám sát nâm dưới,
sáng hỏi quý tế và tức li cà mạnh,
đồng thời không ăn đặt lệnh đống cơ biên dưới họ khảm chế thông mại.
Nhằm chẳng kênh dành đoạn và phát sinh dưới chuyển trải phép không kìm sát,
Về lúc sẽ bố la được tìm chữ là có thể lấy chuyện qua tiếp súc
chứ tiếp với sịch cơ thịnh quyền nhé bệnh,
hoặc vật liệu, Về lúc.